- I have a show!
- You have a show!
- So weird.
- You've always had a show,
but now it's on television.
- You saw the-- (laughing)
- I follow the Instagram,
I've been a fan since day one.
- Ditto, me too.
I mean "All About That Bass" was pretty--
I mean it was meant for me. (laughing)
- Love it.
- And I was like, "did I write that?"
- Did I write this?
- No but in this photo bomb picture
we did with Michelle
Obama, it's pretty great.
- Yes.
- But--
- Oh my (laughing)
- The best part is like, where's waldo,
like find the two
classiest people in there.
- [Meghan] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] That'd be us in the back.
- [Meghan] The blondes, that's us, yeah.
- Everybody else was meant to be there,
and we were like, "what
ever we're crashing."
- I yelled at you, I was like "get in!"
- Well it's Michelle Obama.
- [Meghan] It's our last chance.
- She's so lovely too.
- She's was about to
leave, so that was it.
- [Kelly] I know.
- You're welcome.
- Thank you. (laughing)
I was afraid to ask people
for pictures, are you?
- Oh I just jump on it.
- Oh my god.
- We didn't ask, we just
were in the right place,
at the right time.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
But you also have something
in common with me.
I love having family around,
you travel with your family, right?
They're here today?
- Yes, they are in the front
row, ladies and gentlemen.
(crowd cheering)
I love 'em!
- My family comes to
work with me too, a lot.
Like my whole sometimes.
My husband loves it.
- [Meghan] Awww.
- [Kelly] That's sarcasm.
Yeah he's always like, "cool,
everyone's coming for a week."
- [Meghan] Everyone's here.
- Cool, yeah.
I love it though, I love to be surrounded,
I have a cool family
- Me too, usually they're like
in the green room chillin',
but you were the only one
that let them come out,
and be in the front row!
- I wanted them to come
out, I wanted them to come--
- It's their big day.
- I'm a fan of your dad,
I wish I had a dad like him,
he's so cool.
- Awww.
- Like I had a not good situation--
- [Meghan] I got a cool
dad, I got real lucky.
- You did, I want you to know
to be so grateful for that.
- [Meghan] Oh yes.
- It's such a beautiful thing.
- I am well aware, I cry all the time.
(crowd cheering)
- Anyway, I heard he took
over your social media.
He's really supportive on that.
- He's just really good at it,
and he's really brave at it.
Like he post all the time to support me.
One time he posted my outfit,
right before a big show,
and it was supposed to be a big reveal,
but he posted it with
safety pins and all--
- 'cause he's excited.
- And we were like,
"What are you doin'?"
And he's like, "I'm excited for the show,"
and I was like, "oh, okay."
- [Kelly] I love that!
- It was cute.
- I love you Gary.
- [Meghan] I love you too.
- Oh thank you, thank you so much.
- I do, I love you too.
- Wow, look it!
(kelly laughing)
- [Meghan] He's a superstar.
- [Kelly] Oh my god, I love you.
So now you perform with Meghan, right?
I've heard she's not the
only one gracing the stage.
Do you have a song or something--
- [Meghan] Yes!
On my last album I wrote a
mom song, I love you mom.
And I wrote a dad song,
'cause you can't do one without the other,
- so I did, "Dance Like Yo Daddy."
so, every time I perform this song,
I make my father come on
stage, and dance with me,
and it's pretty hilarious,
and it really gets the crowd going.
- [Kelly] Look at him go, oh my god!
(crowd cheering)
He's so cute.
He is living his best life--
- Look at the booty
- I love you Gary.
You need your own show!
- He does, yeah.
That really like, gets the crowd going.